- On this episode, ET stops by.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
- I don't even do that man.
- [Gary] My man.
- [Eric] Always wanted
to do that.
'Appreciate you man.
(light music)
- [Gary] Crazy day
here in the city.
Rain, a lot of stuff you don't
see on DailyVee is meeting,
meeting, meeting, meeting.
DailyVee is the only thing
I watch because I have to double
check if there's any anything
bad or incriminating or
employee stuff, client stuff
so much information.
And I watch it I'm always like
ugh this really doesn't show me
being the CEO of VaynerMedia.
It shows me being the CEO of
VaynerMedia from a culture
standpoint but not the meeting
I just had with the
CMO of Chase.
Or the pitch meetings that we
have to blur out
that you just saw.
The strategy business meetings
that I can't have any other
agency out there know.
And so, not there yet with
gotta figure it out
'cause it's a day
like yesterday and a day like
today there's so much CEO work
like building an actual business
so trying to figure out, maybe,
actually you know what maybe
the first time I've asked
a question. Very cool.
Maybe in the comments
help us figure it out.
Maybe there's a way where DRock
B-rolls it, and here's an idea,
b-rolls it shows that it
happened and maybe there's a way
to comment on top
of it thematically.
I don't know.
There's a final piece
missing here of
the stuff that helps a,
some of the stuff that I do on
the salesmanship, the product
strategy, the leading the
company and the right
strategic direction.
The four, five things that I've
come up with in the last 90 days
that are gonna
drive our business.
The things that were
gonna sell to clients.
The things are going to help
our clients sell things to you.
These are real things that
are just not being seen here.
When people ask questions like
what everybody at VaynerMedia do
in the background?
They're planning media,
they're creating content.
They're strategizing does
Snapchat matter for your
business or not.
They're doing
those kinds of things.
What is Instagram stories
mean for your business?
Is there partnership
to be done with Uber?
How can your sample integration
into jet.com work now Walmart?
You know, real stuff that
we're not getting through here.
We need to figure that out.
Let me know.
- [Woman] What's something
that makes you nervous?
- The health and well-being
of my inner circle and myself.
First my inner circle because
if my mom was to die in a car
accident today I'm just
not sure what I'm gonna do.
I don't know.
That's the truth.
I care about it so much more
the business that it would, it
probably make you unsteady to
know that I believe that maybe
that would mean I would not care
about anything ever again and
just leave the world.
I'm very, very all into
the things that matter.
I think it's the way I run
this company too for culture.
Right? I just care so much
about this stuff we're talking
about than any
of the other stuff.
And then I just
don't want to die.
I genuinely believe the
company's vulnerability is my
health and well-being.
I genuinely believe that if I
walked in and I don't know how
you're gonna, all of you don't
know me super well but you're
gonna have to take this for
what it is, I believe that if
I walked across a
street in a co-working,
if I want to Think Coffee and
started GaryMedia that I would
put you all of the
business pretty quickly.
So…
(nervous laughter)
- [Man] Don't do it.
- I know that's a
weird thing to say.
Because I know that I'm being
dead fucking serious about what
I'm talking about I'm never
scared of us losing our culture.
We're not going to lose our
culture because I'm going to
fire everybody who's
gonna hurt my culture.
I'm not scared of anything other
than the most important thing.
Time to go?
Can I get one more minute?
How bad is it?
When's the meeting start?
- [Tyler] Now.
- And how far away am I?
And how long is the meeting?
Okay, two more minutes.
(group laughter)
Skybox, look at that.
Skybox.
Where's that sport card thing
from that talk have you seen
have you see me nailing it on
the DailyVee the sports cards?
Did you see my
sports card skills?
How I knew what year
and what player.
- Here's the question is this,
what box does this
maker belong to?
- [Gary] Donruss.
What?
(crowd applause and cheers)
Don't sleep on my skills.
Oh fuck, I have no idea who the
guy Nolan Ryan shared
his rookie card with.
Koosman?
- [Man 2] Koosman is right.
- What? What?
(applause)
- [Man 2] Who's
rookie card is this?
- Ernie Banks?
- [Man 2] Yes.
Ernie Banks.
- [Man 2] Who is this player?
- Roberto Clemente.
- [Man 2] And there he
is Roberto Clemente.
(applause)
- Guys, guys you all know me.
This is the only thing I gave a
fuck about for eight
years of my life.
Think about that much intensity
deployed against one
little narrow thing.
Yeah, you're impressed, right?
Zach? Good.
Hey Natalie.
- [Natalie] Hi.
- What are you doing?
- [Natalie] Just giving a tour
to some of the interns that
just came to see your office.
- Hi guys.
- [Group] Hi.
- How are you?
- [Natalie] They saw you
and I said oh you can say hi.
- Hey, how are you?
I'm Gary.
- I'm John.
- Sake. Nice to meet you.
- How are you?
- James, How are you?
- [Gary] Hey.
- Thomas.
- [Gary] Thomas.
- Erica.
- [Gary] Erica.
- [Nicholas] Nicholas.
- [Gary] Nicholas.
- Carl.
- [Gary] Carl, how are you, man?
Real pleasure.
How's the tour going?
- [Group] Great.
- [Gary] Good.
How's Natalie doing?
- [Group] Wonderful.
- [Gary] She's sweet, right?
I adore her. Awesome.
Have a great week
and a great day.
Doing well?
- [Man 3] Good.
- [Gary] Good.
There's always so
much shit going on now.
I'm always like what the fuck?
- [Emily] Hey Gary.
- Hey Em.
Hey guys.
How are ya?
How are your shows?
Do you guys have some hits?
How many of you are going to
get canceled after
the first episode?
Are you guys happy with the
way you're going about it?
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- [Gary] Fucking Christ,
how fun is it have this
meeting with that view?
Awesome.
Good luck guys,
I'll see you later.
A bunch of you texted me
different shit that I haven't
answered so why don't you
before, why doesn't everybody
gather up what they need from
me interview questions,
did you see this?
Musical.ly, great
all that stuff.
Gather all your questions,
how much time do I have?
- [Tyler] 15 minutes.
- Good you're all gonna roll in.
Andy, 5-0 but for the whole
kit and fuckin' caboodle so
everybody round up, I'm talking
about the text that are in my
thing you gotta watch
this or approve this.
Make sure is that not
theoretical like life questions.
It's been a busy day.
They're all busy, DRock.
(light music)
How's everybody doing?
- [Tyler] Tired.
- [Gary] You're tired?
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- I saw your email last night
at midnight give me some daps.
I love how at 12:30 I'm like
responding and you're like
scheduling shit I'm like Tyler.
Hustling.
He's like the anti-Sid.
(group laughter)
- Come on. Sid's doing
a good job.
- [Gary] Dunk, stay quiet.
(group laughter)
You don't want to
get caught up in there.
Stay out of this.
(group laughter)
I love that you're a
good kid but you'll get
caught up quick in it.
- [Dunk] In what?
- In the negative vibe of Sid.
You don't want to be
part of that ecosystem.
(group laughter)
Wait a minute, what's
going on with the Jets
tickets do I have
four extras tomorrow?
Should I just go in Slack and
be like who wants Jets tickets?
- Pandemonium.
- [DRock] You want me to
film that whole thing?
- What? Film what?
What you mean Jets stuff?
- [DRock] Like the game,
I can go in with you--
- You can't go in film and
film an NFL game.
What are you out of your mind?
What are you gonna be in
the stadium like (sigh).
- [DRock] With the iPhone?
- No, I don't
want you to do that.
- [Man 5] Everybody's
talking on how you relate to us.
- I love it man.
- [Man 5] I appreciate
your time.
- My pleasure, man.
When you going back?
- [Man 5] On Saturday.
- Alright man,
thank you so much.
I think somebody's gonna
create a really cool meme that
everybody's gonna do.
- [Man 6] On takeovers?
- Yeah. I'll leave.
I give a fuck about my haircut.
I love basketball but
I care about my haircut.
I can leave at 7:10, 7:01?
- [Brit] I respect that.
- Thanks Brit.
Brit's got my back.
Clearly Garrett doesn't care
about his haircut but I do.
I just got one
more meeting today.
Bunch of canceled meetings
so DRock you can
have half a day.
See ya.
(hip hop music)